could you maybe not forget again with
you I'm not going to promise that nice
brother you schizophrenia helps me find
in and they will kill you but it will
follow you here and kill old you don't
see him we have to go sweet really
they think they can save me legion all
new next Wednesday at 10:00 on FX and
ethics now
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my legion episode 2 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet they're laying a lot of clues I
love the cerebro look of the MRI machine
they're just tying this to the x-men
universe so there's a new round of the
x-men Logan giveaway it's for IMAX gift
certificates all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment about
Legion on this video so here we go the
big thing that's going on here is
unreliable narration like you don't know
when David is just talking to himself in
his own head like is he talking to other
personalities of his and when is he
talking to real people what is real and
what is a memory like you have that
childhood book the WTF memory about him
killing his mother obviously his parents
didn't read that to him as a child that
would be a super WTF so as we go through
top 10 and WTF I'll try to explain when
the show is giving you clues that David
is talking to other personalities and
they're not real memories like they're
not events that happened in real life
like some of these memories seem like
ways of him interpreting what's going on
inside his mind they talk about mapping
the labyrinth of his memories which is
almost impossible because he has a
thousand different personalities so
number 10 welcome to Summerland
melanie Byrd whisks him away to what
seems like this mutant training facility
where everybody has powers you're also
kind of wondering whether or not this is
real because it seems so dreamlike the
way they give this introduction maybe
it's a situation like episode 1 where
he's in the mental institution looking
at all these different people but really
it might just be him inside his own mind
looking at his other personalities so
they just want you to question that
but right now I'm reading it as melody
is an actual person who's trying to help
him but there are also moments where Sid
does that in sid seems like one of his
other personalities like he has really
evil personalities like the angriest
little boy but he also has calming
personalities to try to help him make
sense of everything so Melanie could be
fake in the sense that she's not a real
person she's someone that David's mind
conjured up but she helps him control
his abilities sort of spells out the
premise of the episode you are a mutant
you were telekinetic you have telepathic
powers so in the context of the series
David doesn't know anything about Mew
he doesn't know anything about his
powers it takes them a while through the
episode before he revisits the outburst
that he had in the kitchen during
episode one that we saw where everything
is flying around so we'll see him do
that in more active ways he did it at
the end of the episode again too when he
used his telepathic powers to visit his
sister number nine the memory training
going back into his memories putana me
the memory artist explains his powers he
has the ability to move through people's
minds he has telepathic powers too
that sort of explains the twist in
episode 1 how Sid was talking to David
inside one of his memories they can't
track us here so that was probably
putana me that was helping put her in
there but again it's another mind trip
because you wonder at times if putana me
is real because the way he snaps his
fingers for David to wake him up is also
the same way his sister snaps her
fingers back in his memory so the museum
of you gets this great explainer you can
talk to the memories but it will change
them sort of like rewriting old files on
a hard drive with new information so
number eight the WTF childhood memory
this is like the terrible memory
that he takes them back to at the end of
the episode they're really vague about
it but they make it sound based on that
childhood rhyme like he had a telepathic
telekinetic outburst and it killed his
mother and he didn't really understand
what happened and that led to him slowly
going crazier and crazier as he got
older the other thing that they're
laying here I love the way they do this
is they obscure his father's face like
he can't see it so I think they're just
trying to play up the idea of his father
being Professor X there's some language
later on my WTF list where I'll explain
that where he talks about looking at the
stars number 7 is David being the key to
winning the war so this is where you get
into the larger context of the x-men
universe this is why some of the people
in the series are meant to be real and
some are meant to be fake but they don't
want to explain who's fake and who's
real right away that's part of the
mystery of the series and unraveling the
nature of David's powers so all that's
important right now is that you think of
division 3 the group that's chasing him
the I the villain of the series is a
Weapon X type program they're the bad
guys they want to use him to win their
side of the war in the emergence of all
these mutants mutant kind the
Brotherhood of
using any group that works towards the
benefit of mutant kind like the Hellfire
Club you can think of being on the other
side of this but they're also very
ambiguous about that because it seems
like the series takes place around
first-class days the future path but the
elevator has voice-activated controls at
the end so they're just messing with
your head making you wonder what's real
what time period are we in it's meant to
be very ambiguous in that way number 6
is sid remembering killing Lenny she's
like oops sorry I did that I think I
killed your friend and they explained
the twist with how Sid came to be
working with these people
again this is presuming that Sid is an
actual person in not just one of David's
other personalities but I love the twist
in the car ride where she reverts to
herself in their super surprise like
they didn't know that it wasn't David
when he got in the car so the way
they're playing it it's like the body
swapping is a separate thing all these
other people in the car are real they're
not David's other personalities in are
genuinely amazed at the idea that this
is Sid like they didn't think that Sid
got in the car they thought that David
got in the car number 5 is Carrie
Loudermilk testing his abilities this
again also kind of flips you on your
head making you wonder who's real who's
fake because Carrie Loudermilk talks to
himself in the way that David does so
there are a lot of characters in the
series that have the same sort of
nervous tics that David has so you're
like wait a minute is it just another
aspect of his personality when he's in
the machine they also give you some more
clues about other personalities so he
goes back to memories of Lenny we
remember he didn't really meet Lenny
till he was in the psychiatric facility
so what I think is going on is that
Lenny is another one of his
personalities and when his hair is all
messed up like Lenny's that's when that
personality is dominant so when he's in
the alleyway and Lenny is trying to get
drugs here talking to this Greek about
killing himself it's almost like one of
his personalities is telling another
personality to kill himself but it's
also the Lenny personality telling him
to kill himself because he's so
depressed about his girlfriend leaving
him in not understanding what's going on
he doesn't understand his powers so he
has suicidal tendencies so there's just
more evidence that his personalities are
talking to him exerting influence on him
Lenny is just one of the more
chaotic personalities that he has and I
love the idea of him high-fiving his own
personality like he's high-fiving
himself in his own mind but number four
is the frog vaping I love the way the
frogs eyes light up like it gets really
psychedelic and then they jump out as if
they're watching that memory happen so
they're seamlessly transitioning between
him being in his memories in them
examining his memories so they really
want you to think that Melanie putana me
are separate people they're actually
real they're not alternate personalities
so that's another big idea hopefully
they'll explain in later episodes
whether or not Davis different
personalities are aware of each other in
whether or not they can interact
independent of David's normal mind so
you have like David Prime you have his
will then you have the alternate
personality that each have their own
memories in their own will - because in
the comics he can actually manifest them
as physical people in the real world but
we don't know how trippy the series is
going to get and how many characters
will actually turn out to be alternate
personalities because it is a lot to ask
of the audience where like at the end of
the series that they're like it was all
in his head the whole time I feel like a
lot of people would be really upset by
that it's cool if a couple of the
personalities are inside of it but if
everything is inside is that then that
would probably be bad so you want to
have division three as this separate
entity that exists in the real world
then you want to have a couple of these
people that are talking to him be fake
then you want to have a good group
that's actually real - so number three
is him talking about his father the
constellations this is really cool x-men
Professor X stuff they're teasing here
so he talks about his father taking him
to look at the starch they lived in
upstate New York which conveniently is
where Professor X's mansion is they used
to talk to me I told my father about it
Eenie says that they would talk to him
too now what's the thing about cerebro
on x-men is that when Professor X is
using it it looks like he's stargazing
all the little people where he's
telepathically speaking to all them so
it's almost like they're saying that
David was inside cerebro as a child but
the way he explains it is that his
father was helping him talk to his other
personalities he says that he's not
supposed to repeat what those voices
told him they
implies that there's some really dark
voices that are telling him to do really
bad things the darker aspects of his
personality like you have the CID people
who seem like she might be fake but
really benevolent trying to help him but
you also have the devil with yellow eyes
who might just be a darker aspect of his
personality too so I really like the way
David is talking about his father
helping him work through his personality
problem but it also sounds like he's
standing inside cerebro so eventually
they will tie this to the bigger x-men
universe but that's more of a season 2
thing so it does kind of feel like
they're building up towards a professor
x-type revealed but you guys can let me
know when he's talking about stars
talking to the other personalities and
he said does that not sound like cerebro
number 2 cool action set piece he gets
really pissed off inside the MRI machine
and just zaps it outside the way this
looks this room he didn't tear it
through a wall
he literally teleported it outside the
building so they're getting really weird
with the way his powers work because
that wouldn't be telekinesis that would
be something completely different
Melanie smiling here seems to imply that
she's a real person she's not a
different personality of David but
number one is the post-credits with his
sister being taken by division 3 getting
ready to be interrogated because they're
looking for David it also seems like
she's a real person - so the big twist
is when he sees her in the hospital
trying to find him there's no David here
we've never had a patient like that
he sort of manifests that's him reaching
out to her telepathically trying to
speak to her the eye almost seems like
he can tell that Dave is doing this like
oh I can see you using your powers I'm
going to take your sister so that we can
track you down so it's a really solid
episode but you guys can let me know how
many of these people do you think are
different personalities of David's in
how many do you think are actually real
that's going to be the big question
through every episode what's going to
happen next is I have new Black Panther
there's new Star Wars Episode eight I've
got the new Spider Man so I'll try to
get that stuff out as fast as possible
but leave all your Legion questions in
the comments and also congratulations to
the new Logan giveaway winner Allen
caddy please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details it was a new round and
this video I'll announce the winner the
next time I post an x-men Deadpool Logan
video while you wait for that you can
click here for the Thor
ragnarok teaser and you can click here
for the Logan WTF origin see thank you
so much for watching everyone let's high
five I'll see you in the next video
you